- [Instructor] What we are going to try
to understand in this video
is the balance of payments.
And it's really how a country accounts for
the different ways that money
is flowing into the country
or payments are happening into a country
or payments are happening
outside of a country.
And right over here, I have information
for the United States in 2011,
all of the numbers right over here
are denominated in dollars.
And in green I have all of
the reasons why currency
or why payments would be made to the US
either the government of the US,
the federal reserve of the US,
or to citizens of the US.
And in orange, I have all the reasons
why payments would be made
to folks outside of the US,
either the government, central banks,
or private citizens.
And for this video, I'm
going to first focus
on the left hand, these
reasons right over here.
And this you could view,
this is the current account.
The current account.
And the current account focuses on things
related to trade, so exports and imports,
things related to income in that period,
so if I'm getting dividends from a stock
that's a German company
or if someone in Germany
is getting dividends from a stock
that's an American company,
and just transfers of money.
I give money to my mom in
France to help support her.
So that's what factored
in in the current account.
In the next video, we will
talk about the capital account,
the capital account, which focuses
on transfers or payments that are due to
changes in ownership of assets
and we'll see how they all balance out
either in the next video or
maybe the video after that.
But let's first focus
on the current account.
So in green, I have all the reasons why
the US got payments from the
rest of the world in 2011.
So the first one right
over here is exports.
You can imagine if we are exporting,
and this is in billions, so this is 2.1,
this is 2,105 billion
which is the same thing
as 2.1 trillion.
If we're exporting 2.1 trillion dollars
worth of goods and services,
then the rest of the world
is going to have to pay that much to us.
So this is going to be an inflow,
this is going to be a payment,
this is a reason why we have more dollars
after all the appropriate
currency transactions take place,
why more dollars have to come to the US,
either to US private
citizens, to the government,
or to the federal reserve.
And for the most part, this is going to be
for private citizens or corporations.
And this right over here is income
that Americans get from
owning assets abroad
in other countries.
So imagine that I, I'm
an American citizen,
I own an apartment complex in London,
the folks in London have
to pay rent on that,
I convert that rent to
dollars and I bring it back
to the US, that would be
an income receipt to me.
It's the reason why currency or payments
are being made to the US.
And so once again, that's why I've colored
these right over here in green.
Now let's think about the
other side of that coin.
Obviously, we're not just selling stuff
to the rest of the world,
the rest of the world
is selling stuff to us.
And that's what imports are factoring in
and the US actually runs a trade deficit.
It imports more than
it exports to the tune,
if we wanted to round, of
about 2.7 trillion dollars.
And once again, if we're
buying other people's goods
and services, we needed
to make payments to them.
Currency needs to go to them.
And so you see it's to the tune,
and that's why I wrote it
right over here of in orange.
And once again, income payments,
other side of income receipts.
This is foreigners owning
assets in the United States.
If a foreigner owns a pizza
parlor in the United States,
that pizza parlor makes a
$100,000 in a given year,
and that $100,000 will
go to that foreigner,
it will be an income payment.
And so that's what this
factors in right over here.
This is income on foreign-owned assets.
It does not go into an American.
It does not go to the American government
or private citizen or corporation
or the federal reserve.
It goes to someone outside of the country.
And so this would be
an outflow of payments
outside of the country.
And so this last part right over here,
this is net transfers.
This is literally just on a net basis,
Americans giving money away
to the rest of the world.
And it actually since
Americans give away more
than they receive from
the rest of the world,
we're not talking about transactions,
this is kind of just pure
I'm an American citizen,
I give money to my mom and friends,
or this could even be foreign aid,
the US government giving aid to a country,
and since the US does give
more than it receives,
we just write it down
on a net transfer basis
and it is right over here a net outflow.
And so we can figure out looking at this,
while just based on these causes,
the trade deficit, the income receipts,
and the net transfers, where the US
is transferring more currency abroad
or getting more currency onto,
I guess you could say, into its ownership.
And to do that, let's
get our calculator out.
Let me get the calculator out.
And so let's think.
Okay, so this is all of the money
that we are getting.
These are the payments, these
are the inflows to the US.
So let's add those up, 2,105 billion
plus 739 billion,
and now let's subtract
out all of the outflows
of capital or I should
say all of the outflows
of currency from the US.
All of the payments that go out of the US.
So let's subtract, so the
payments we have to make
due to imports, so 2.7 trillion
and then we have the 518 billion of income
that foreigners make on US assets.
And then finally, or
foreign-owned assets of the US,
or in the US I should say,
and then the money that
the US just gives away
to the rest of the world on a net basis.
And you see here, when you just
look at the current account,
the US is running a
current account deficit.
For just these causes alone,
the US is making more payments
than it is receiving.
And it's to the tune
of 474 billion dollars.
So let me write it right over here.
So our current account,
current account deficit
is to the tune, I already
forgot the number,
474 billion dollars.
If that number was
positive, I would call it
a current account surplus.